Ja, ganz schön früh noch, oder?
Ja, guck mal, 8.45 Uhr, so früh sind wir normalerweise nie.
Hab ich den Streamer auf der richtigen Kategorie?
Gucken.
Ja.
Ja, you're just chatting, just chatting, uff, wait, keck, keck, wait, keck, keck, wait.
Moin, vor der Stream möchte ich los, Git, muss mal kurz meine wöchentliche Sache gucken
auf GitHub, was trendet, nein, nein, nein, nein, weekly, juckt mich nicht, juckt mich
nicht, juckt mich nicht, juckt mich nicht, juckt mich nicht, juckt mich nicht, juckt
mich bisschen, juckt mich nicht, juckt mich nicht, juckt mich nicht, juckt mich auch nicht,
auch nicht auch nicht auch nicht auch nicht auch nicht auch nicht auch nicht auch nicht auch nicht
auch nicht
Okay nice, nichts dabei diese Woche, was mich irgendwie auch in Ansatzweise juckt.
Viel zu früh noch, wobei jedenfalls wird es jetzt eine Viertelstunde
Unterschied ausmachen.
Ich bin gerade aufgestanden, so wie es einem da halt so geht.
Oh ich muss mal kurz Mails was gucken. Was machen denn die ganzen Sponsoring-Dudes?
Nachdem das Genshin-Sponsoring ja so gut angekommen ist, werde ich auf diese Art
und Weise sicherlich noch mehr vorlesen in nächster Zeit. Mich hat ein
China-Chinesen, wie nennt man das, so Kleingeräte, Elektro-Kleinteilgeräte-
Hersteller angefragt, wie es aussieht mit Gerätvorstellen. Also quasi so ein
Hersteller, der Handyhalterung macht, Netzteile macht und irgendwie sowas, da
bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob ich das machen soll. Ich habe zwar selbst von
denen ein paar, aber das ist preislich nicht so interessant und naja, was soll ich
dazu erzählen? Soll ich 60 Sekunden eine Handyhalterung zeigen oder was?
Martin in offiziellen Musik, erste Chatnachricht. Moin.
Ja, es ist, glaube ich, relativ sinnlos, sowas zu machen.
Der Gerät ist auch immer vor dem Chef im Geschäft oder
irgendwie so.
Also nee, das Sponsoring von dem China-Chinesen Elektronikteilehersteller
werde ich nicht machen. No Pass. Sub End, Dankeschön, zwei Monate Subscription.
Massive Subs, ja. Moin, El Sar.
Oh, ich muss heute, es ist heute noch was, fällt mir gerade ein, ich muss noch was
überweisen ans Finanzamt, ich muss noch Elektrikerrechnungen bezahlen und ich
muss noch Zahnarztrechnungen bezahlen, das wüsste ich mal machen.
C++ Updates, es gab doch jetzt letztens ein neues C, eine neue C-Version, oder?
Doch, habe ich doch zuletzt gelesen, C 2022 oder sowas, der sich im Vergleich zu
C++ tatsächlich irgendwie noch ganz sinnig liest.
Allerdings sind da wohl auch, haben da irgendwelche C++ Leute ihre Hände mit
drin, das heißt, demnächst arte das auch aus.
Allerdings ist das ja immer gerade bei solchen Standards nicht so das
großartige Problem, das dauert ja eh 20 Jahre, bis das irgendwo umgesetzt ist.
Das ist genauso wie C++ in die Header Files loswerden wird.
Moin, schon über die neuste Exchange-Lücke, was ist da, zeige ich mal her,
habe ich nicht mitgekriegt. BSI, wenn sogar das BSI vorwarnt, bin ich
aber ganz schön langsamer, dass wir mitkriegen.
Moment Leute, Sekunde, Sekunde, 0-day Attack-at-Microsoft-Exchanger,
Sicherheit-Patches fehlen. Na ja gut, da freuen sich jetzt alle,
die Exchange über Office 365 verwenden, ich sehe nicht, ja doch, ist
wahrscheinlich Exchange, Outlook 365, die freuen sich jetzt, weil die
wahrscheinlich nicht das Problem haben.
Okay, Sicherheitsbranche waren, dass das Angreifen derzeit doppelt,
naja, es ist dann eine 0-0-Day-Lücke.
Ein Workaround.
Okay, also was muss man machen?
Ihnen zufolge sollen Angreifer aus dem China-Chinesischen Umfeld-Exchange-Server
erfolgreich, was sonst?
Vielleicht haben die auch einfach nur den VPN verwendet, aber ich kann es
mir durchaus vorstellen, dass die China-Chinesen gleich wieder am Start
sind.
Ich habe gehört, der Rockstar-Hackerman wurde angeblich festgenommen.
Mittlerweile haben weitere Sicherheitsvorteile runter, auch Trend-Microsoft.
Details sind bislang kaum veröffentlicht, das ist ja langweilig.
Was sagt denn Microsoft dazu?
Okay, was muss man, was ist das wieder für komisches, obskures, was muss man
machen, um Systeme aber jetzt schon zu schützen haben, die Sicherheitsvorteile
nicht zu schützen haben, also dann muss man einfach mal eine Anfrage
machen, um eine Anfrage in der Attacke zu blocken.
Dafür müssen Admets unter Auto-Discovery im Tab Ull rewrite eine Request-Blocking-Regel.
Achso, das ist das Exchange, irgendwelche Sachen, wisst ihr, eine Sache regt mich
generell bei Server-Software auf, wenn die automatisch irgendwelche Dinge macht,
die ich nicht explizit eingeschaltet habe.
Und zwar dann irgendwas als Ergebnis rauskommt, was ich eigentlich gar nicht haben will.
Mit folgendem PowerShell-Commando könne Admets prüfen, ob die Server bereits kompromittiert
sind.
Naja, solange die irgendwelche Hinterlassenschaften haben.
Ah, es gibt sogar ein offizielles Shell-Skip, was den Workaround macht, na dann, warum ist
das nicht, warum ist das hier, naja, genauer Erklärung gibt's wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Ok, autorifizierte Angreifer kann Remote das da triggern.
Und das da gibt's keine großartigen, na gut, das ist ja nur die Erklärung, keine großartigen
Erklärungen zu, ha?
8,8 von 8,3, alles klar.
Ja, viele Infos gibt's dazu tatsächlich noch nicht.
Naja, ich halt mal wieder irgendwelcher Microsoft-Shit, na.
Microsoft, generell, ganz im Ernst, alles was ich bisher mitbekommen habe von dem Microsoft-Support
ist auch wirklich richtig schlecht gewesen.
Also, wir haben ja relativ viel auf der Arbeit, was Azure angeht von Microsoft und wir haben
auch jede Menge Support-Geschichten und sonst was von Microsoft und jedes Mal, wenn du bei
denen was an, wenn du dort irgendeine Support-Anfrage machst, dann läuft's eigentlich darauf raus,
dass es keine hilfreiche Antwort gibt.
Naja, wenn du Support bei denen gekauft hast, kriegst du auch Support, da kannst du bei
denen ein Ticket aufmachen oder Support-Anfrage stellen.
Also, du stellst bei Microsoft eine Support-Anfrage, was weiß ich ja, keine Ahnung hier, warum
hängt mein Service beim Starten, so, irgendwas, ja und dann bekommst du eine Antwort, wir
haben den Eindruck, dass sie Probleme haben den Service zu starten, haben sie schon mal
versucht den Service zu starten, sollte diese Antwort ihnen geholfen haben, bitte Ticket
schließen.
So, ungefähr so auf diesem Niveau bewegt sich dann die erste Antwort und warum ist das
so?
Weil nicht die Hilfe bezahlt wird, sondern Reaktionszeiten bezahlt werden.
Das ist so ein typischer Fall von falschen Anreizen irgendwie.
Generell ist es total bescheuert, es ist gang und gäbe, ich weiß, es ist gang und gäbe,
aber es ist total bescheuert für, wie soll ich sagen, reine Reaktion zu bezahlen, weil
reine Reaktion kann auch sein, hallo, wir haben das Ticket erhalten und weitergeleitet
oder hallo, ich bin, ich bin Second Level Techniker und bitte starten sie den Service noch, das
ist halt alles Reaktion, deswegen schreibt Microsoft innerhalb von 2-3 Stunden so ein
absolut unsinniges Kommentar rein und dann kannst du sagen, ja natürlich hab ich den
Service versucht zu starten, er startet nicht, deswegen hab ich das Ticket noch bei euch
aufgemacht.
Und dann kommt selten was raus, also Microsoft Support, generell Support ist zum größten
Teil komplett verschwendetes Geld, du musst dich entweder eh selbst rum kümmern oder
dir was anderes suchen, es ist ganz selten in Fällen, dass es wirklich mal was gebracht
hat, auch wenn du Oracle Support hast oder sowas, es ist jetzt nicht so, als setzen die
da irgendwie Entwickler hin und fixen für dich irgendeinen Bug oder so, wenn du Glück
hast, haben die irgendeine interne Knowledge Base, wo sie dir den Link zu schicken, wo
du nur drauf zugreifen kannst, wenn du einen Account bei denen hast, wo steht, wie du das
Feature irgendwie umbiegen kannst, dass es doch funktioniert, also die meisten Support
Dinger sind wirklich relativ sinnlos.
Also die einzige Sache, wo es tatsächlich sinnvoll ist mit dem Support zu schreiben
beziehungsweise wo es sich auch lohnt ist Hardware, also wenn man irgendwelche Server gekauft
hat, wobei jetzt eher Lenovo oder HP oder Dell und dort geht was kaputt und man braucht
Ersatzteile, das ist eigentlich ganz gut, da machst du bei denen was auf oder sagst
bei denen Bescheid und dann kriegst du ein neues Netzteil geschickt.
Das ist ok, bei IBM hast du früher die Frunummer gebraucht, falls das noch irgendjemand kennt,
es war auch immer so ein Ding, jedes Teil was austauschbar war bei IBM, die hatten so
ein Aufkleber drauf mit einer Frunummer, das Problem war nur die Frunummer war meistens
an irgendwelchen Stellen, zum Beispiel hier irgendwo auf dem Ram oder sowas, die war meistens
auf irgendwelchen Stellen, wo du halt ohne das System aufzumachen oder zumindest rauszuziehen
oder auszuschalten nicht wirklich was gesehen hast, bis auf die ganz offensichtlichen und
das konntest du halt nicht machen, weil meistens die Systeme ja nicht kaputt waren, sondern
halt ein Netzteil von zwei oder so, ja gut das Netzteil konntest du rausziehen, aber
ihr versteht was ich meine und dann musstest du immer ewig diskutieren mit dem IBM Support.
Ne die bezahlen Reaktionszeiten, das ist ja das Problem, das ist ja bei vielen Supports
so, dass du Reaktionszeiten bezahlst und nicht wirklich sinnvolle Lösungen, deswegen tut
sich da auch meistens nichts, die reagieren dann auf die Anfrage und sagen ja wir haben
unsere SLAs erfüllt und tschüss. Stimmt, ich bin so froh, dass ich mit Microsoft Zeug
nichts zu tun hab, ganz im Ernst, ich hab letztens ne Bewerbung gesehen von einem Bewerbungskandidat
bei uns, das war die krasseste Bewerbung, die ich je gesehen hab, das waren sieben Seiten,
oh leckt der Streamer, was ist hier los, Vodafone please, oh hier, was ist da los, das war der
krasseste Lebenslauf bzw. krasseste Skillliste aller Zeiten, das waren sieben Seiten und da
war alles drauf Leute, ihr könnt es euch, es war wirklich alles drauf, da war Sachen
drauf, Windows, Linux, Solaris und dann standen noch die einzelnen Derivate drauf, Distributionen
drauf, Debian, CentOS, Red Hat, Windows 2003, Windows 2008, C++, Ruby, Bash, alles, alles,
der hatte wirklich sieben Seiten Skills, das war natürlich nicht von ihm geschrieben, das
hat irgendein Vermittlungstyp geschrieben, der halt gedacht hat, ok, viel hilf, viel,
das kann der im Leben nicht alles auf dem Niveau, dass man ihn dafür einkaufen würde,
es ist so wie wenn ich Cobol in meinen Lebenslauf schreiben würde, ihr wisst, ich hab Cobol
Erfahrung, ich hab Cobol Erfahrung, was jetzt aber nicht heißt, dass ich das unbedingt
in meinen Lebenslauf schreiben würde, aber ungefähr auf dem Niveau wird sich einiges
dann dort bewegen, es ist egal, also total was da teilweise reinkommt, weirdchamp, geil
zwar immer noch, der gemeint hat, seine Abschlussarbeit ist geheim, da darf er nichts drüber erzählen,
dass diese Woche noch irgendwas spannendes passiert, zeig mal kurz, irgendwas interessantes
gewesen, als Körperthermostat, übrigens das eine Sache stört mich bei Heise auch zunehmend,
dass der Newsticker so versteckt ist und um rauszukriegen ob eine News interessant ist,
muss man einfach nach den Comments gucken, Platz auf der Fernbedienung, ich brauch auch
keine Fernbedienung, ich brauch keinen Button für irgendwelche Sender, schummeln beim Schach,
wie kann man überhaupt bescheißen beim Schach, wie kann man bescheißen bei, aber das ist
online, ja online kann man natürlich bescheißen, aber bei Offline Turnieren stelle ich es mir
schwer vor zu bescheißen, also dass man online bescheißen kann, ok, wie langweilige News,
langweilig, glasfaser jetzt umsteigen, die lecken critical information, bei mir gibt
es keine glasfaser, dann würde ich auch umsteigen, Offline, was mit Perlen, hat ihm dann im Publikum
irgendeiner Signale gegeben oder wie, ey ohne Scheiß unsere Gesundheitskarte, das ist auch
so ein Abfack, was sie nicht richtig hinkriegen werden, GitHub führt private Profile ein,
echt, hab ich da mitgekriegt, ja warum nicht, danke schön für den Sub, alles in Gucci,
ok nix friend ist dabei, Internet Sperren im Iran, ich hab gelesen Dota 2 ist jetzt gebannt
im Iran, ja Dota 2 banned im Iran irgendwo, im Irak, ja was auch immer irgendwo, ist aus
irgendwelchen Gründen Dota gebannt, weiß nicht, nicht aller approved oder so, ich weiß
eh nicht warum man Spiele banned, aber gut, ja dabei, keine Ahnung, bei manchen Regierungen
in manchen Ländern wundert man sich echt über nix mehr, das USB Firm hat schon wieder
gebannt, wirklich, es wird mich nicht wundern, Moment, zeig mal, ja, wo denn, USB branding
changed again, oh ne ich guck mir doch jetzt keine 2 Stunden an USB, redesigned logos finally
make sense, ist ein Timestamp, ok, zeig mal, kein Timestamp im Video, oder hier unten,
ahja hier unten, USB, ok, Sekunde, zeig mal, ich blick nicht mehr durch, ich hab zu viele
Tipps, make waves, USB implementers forum is changing the branding again, I just wanna
give a shout out to GD Felt over on the forum, long time member, first time poster, I actually
don't know if you're a long time member, first post on the forum, in 2019, ok so why don't
we go through some of what has lead up to this moment, in 2019, not a long time member,
the USB IF implemented the following name changes, they took USB 3.0, which was pretty
self explanatory, das muss man ja sagen, bis USB 3.0 waren die Sachen eigentlich halbwegs
in Ordnung, bzw. bis USB 3.1 waren die Sachen eigentlich halbwegs in Ordnung noch, you
had your USB 1 and 1.1, ok, that was the slow one, then you had your USB 2, ok, that was
the fast one, then you had your USB 3, that was the faster one, ok, easy, die hatten ja
irgendwie, was hatten die bei USB, super speed, ultra speed, ok, they renamed USB 3.0, which
was good, to USB 3.1 gen 1, ja genau, die haben 3.1 retroaktiv umbenannt dann, nee Schwachsinn,
ah ich blick nicht mehr durch, genau, die haben dann das immer retroaktiv umbenannt,
dass die neue Version, dass die alten Version die Versionsnummer von der neuen Version trugen
und sowas, das echte 3.1, gen 2x2, achso, das war gen 2x2,
denn das Problem ist halt, dass USB viel mehr ist als einfach nur die Geschwindigkeit,
oh jetzt wird die Highlight gemessagt im Chat, das ist, es scheint mir ein neues Feature
zu sein, wurde gestern auch gefragt, ob ich meine Nachricht nicht hervorheben will für
6 Euro oder sowas, da hab ich mir auch gedacht, nein, aber das ist ja noch für Channelpoint,
ja ok, ach das wars jetzt oder wie, ich sag doch die ganze Zeit auch schon, die sollen
es so machen, wie das beispielsweise bei Wifi 5, Wifi 6 gemacht wurde, gut, warum wir jetzt
Wifi 6 e brauchen, gut, naja ok, es macht doch tatsächlich mal ein bisschen mehr Sinn.
So, ich wollte noch ein bisschen Tee trinken, so ist ja Bescheid, dass die USB Benahmung
angeblich besser wird, mal gucken ob das auch der Fall ist oder ob die nächstes Jahr
diesen Kram dann wieder umbenennen in 2023 Gen 2.1 5x3, ja das wollen sie jetzt ja anscheinend
machen, das wollen sie jetzt ja anscheinend machen, allerdings intern heißt der Krempel
immer noch so, aber wohl auf den Logos, ach was weiß ich was die da treiben, da blickt
wirklich keiner mehr durch, ja HDMI blickt auch keiner mehr durch, das ist richtig, das
hab ich aber auch aufgegeben bei HDMI mittlerweile komplett, zum Glück muss man sich mit HDMI
nicht so oft auseinandersetzen, warst du schon mal auf einer Expertenkonferenz, nö, nicht
dass ich mich, nichts was ich als Expertenkonferenz klassifizieren würde, wo gehst du denn hin?
EMCC von iSystem, von denen hab ich schon mal was gehört, nee keine Ahnung, auch sowas
war ich noch nicht, ich mag Konferenzen eh nicht sonderlich und messen auch nicht, ja
ich hoffe dein Chef bezahlt es, ja das stimmt schon, allerdings gerade im Entertainment-Bereich
ist HDMI halt immer noch angesagt, also was Fernsehanschließen und sowas angeht, das
ist halt HDMI und es wird wahrscheinlich auch erstmal HDMI bleiben, oder wie ist das
Leute, ich hab noch kein Fernseh gesehen und irgendwelche Media-Player die Display-Port
verwenden, ich will gar nicht ausschließen, dass mein Fernseh nicht sogar theoretisch
einen Display-Port hätte, ich glaub der könnte sogar einen Display-Port haben, aber normalerweise
wird das nicht, also mein Player hat, also die Android TV hat keinen Display-Port, ja
ein bisschen aber nicht wirklich groß zu merken, es haben ja seit Jahren, wenn nicht sogar
seit 10 Jahren oder so mittlerweile, die gängigen CPUs, Krypto-Extensions für die Standard-Verschlüsselungs-Algorithmen,
also das merkst du nicht, theoretisch schon, praktisch nicht, ich hab auch alle meine SSDs
verschlüsselt und alle meine HDDs verschlüsselt, das ist überhaupt kein Ding, ich weiß nicht,
habe ich ein SSD-Benchmark, hätte ich euch mal zeigen können, das macht keinen Unterschied,
das ist fast nicht messbar der Unterschied, wieso eigentlich, wieso eigentlich was, warum
ich nicht gerne auf Konferenzen oder irgendwelche Messen gehe oder so, sind mir einfach zu
viele Leute, zu viele Leute, zu viele Leute die mich überhaupt nicht interessieren und
meistens halt auch zu wenig auf der Messe selbst was mich interessiert, gerade Gamescom
ist ein gutes Beispiel für die kannst du halt eigentlich komplett vergessen, ich weiß
bis heute nicht warum Leute auf die Gamescom fahren, ich mein wir hatten ja noch ein bisschen
Glück, wir hatten diese Area wo man sich ein bisschen hinsetzen kann, wir haben im Vorfeld
Termine gemacht so dass man eben nicht 3 Stunden anstehen muss, das ging ja noch halbwegs und
ich fand es schon so schon kacke, aber wenn man da einfach nur hingeht und sich 3 Stunden
dran entstanden ist, keine Ahnung, ich verstehe nicht warum man da hingeht, richtig, das ist
das, das ist das was so ein Storage Treiber macht, also unter der Haube ist das auf der
Disk, also hier, guckt mal, also die Platten die sehen jetzt zwar unverschlüsselt aus,
sind aber verschlüsselt, die sind nur entschlüsselt quasi im laufenden Betrieb, was ist entschlüsselt,
im laufenden Betrieb sind die Keys geladen so dass man sie ver- und entschlüsseln kann,
sobald ich den Rechner ausschalte sind die Dinger verschlüsselt
und dann machst du da nichts, ja gut, wenn es eine Embedded Conference ist, dass dann
Experten über Embedded Software sprechen, klingt jetzt erstmal nachvollziehbar, ist
das parallelisierbar, muss dich nicht interessieren, du verwendest die Krypto Extensions deiner
CPU, ich gehe davon aus, dass es davon mehrere gibt und die parallel Sachen verarbeiten können,
aber jede halbwegs aktuelle Software verwendet die CPU Krypto Extensions, also bei Intel
heißen die Dinger zum Beispiel so und mach mal einen Benchmark bei dir, du wirst quasi
sehen wieviel da pro Sekunde durchgeht, das ist eigentlich keine Verschlechterung zu ohne
Verschlüsselung zu verwenden, kann VeracupLux öffnen, ist eine gute Frage, ich glaube nicht,
keine Ahnung und das File System was dann drauf ist höchstwahrscheinlich kann Windows
nichts mit anfangen, weil da ist ja wahrscheinlich dann X4 oder XFS oder sowas drunter, obendrauf,
nicht drunter obendrauf, ich hab keine Ahnung ob VeracupLux öffnen kann, aber wahrscheinlich
nicht, ne, nutz ich nicht, nutz das da, nicht BitLocker, BitLocker hat mich abgeschreckt,
direkt von Anfang an als Microsoft mal veröffentlicht hat, man könnte über irgendwelche Wege, wenn
man ein Passwort verloren hat, könnte man irgendwie sein Passwort restoren lassen, kam
ganz am Anfang mal als News raus, da brauchst du kein Tutorial, du klickst einfach den
Assistent durch und dann ist dein System verschlüsselt, ganz am Anfang gab es eine News, ich weiß
gar nicht ob da wirklich, ob das so schlimm ist wie es sich angehört hat, aber das hat
mich komplett abgeschreckt von BitLocker, als der erste News die ich von BitLocker gehört
hab ist, dass du irgendwie dein Passwort restoren lassen kannst über dein Microsoft Account
oder sowas und als ich gehört habe, die bieten eine Festplattenverschlüsselung an, bei der
man das Passwort restoren kann, hab ich gewusst, ok das ist scheiße, jegliche Verschlüsselung
wo irgendjemand anderes dein Passwort restoren kann bzw. dein Key restoren kann ist scheiße,
ordentlich verschlüsselt heißt Passwort weg alles verloren, ja wie gesagt ich weiß gar
nicht was da genau dran ist, zumindest hab ich das so aus den News damals rausgelesen
rein interpretiert und seitdem hab ich nie wieder auch nur dran gedacht BitLocker zu
verwenden.
Gibt es bestimmt, stellt dir mal vor irgendein Geschäfts, irgendein Business Notebook ist
BitLocker verschlüsselt und hat dort wichtige Sachen drauf und vergisst dein Passwort,
das kann man bestimmt so einstellen, dass die Firma das wieder entschlüsseln kann
und sowas, kannst du bestimmt irgendeinen Backup Key im AD speichern und das kann dann
nur der Admin wieder herstellen, das ist alles Müll, ganz ehrlich alle Verschlüsselungen
die du wieder herstellen kannst außer mit dem original Passwort ist Crap, wie gesagt
für VeraCrypt brauchst du kein Tutorial, du machst das auf, wählst aus was du haben
willst, entweder Vollverschlüsselung von der Systemplatte oder eben Verschlüsselung
erst nach dem Boot bzw. einhängen erst nach dem Boot und nach dem Windows Start einhängen
und das wars, mehr musst du nicht machen, kann euch empfehlen bei VeraCrypt Key Files
zu verwenden und nicht Passwörter oder Passwörter mit Keyfile, aber am besten ist die Festplatte,
also ich machs so, ich hab meine Festplatte verschlüsselt mit Vollverschlüsselung und
die anderen mach ich über Keyfile, die einmalig entsperrt werden müssen, ansonsten müsste
ich dann eben für 3 Platten immer Passwörter eintippen oder für 4 Platten Passwörter eintippen,
das wäre zu doof, ok Dualboot weiß ich nicht, das könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es damit
Probleme hat, Dualboot habe ich noch nie ausprobiert in der Kombi, da hätte ich aber auch meine
Bedenken ob das funktioniert, ja, Dualboot ist irgendwas das würde ich da in der Kombination
wahrscheinlich nicht machen, so Youtube du hast nochmal die Chance uns was sinnvolles
zu empfehlen, nimmst du Bitlocker, nee, Exposed, das Netzwerk der Klimaleugner, es geht schon
wieder los hier, die gefährlichste Cyberwaffe, der übertreibt es immer so mit den Titeln,
yeah, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Boi, Chat, zisch, nee, zlscheib, was kann ich aussprechen, aber boi, major changes,
oh ja, massive changes, diese Titel ist immer der gleiche Chebat, ja, immer der gleiche
Chebat, die Leute glauben's.
Wir haben gestern die Major Changes gespielt, hat erstmal dazu geführt, dass die Lobby
kaputt war.
Ich habe ein Jahr jedes Video in den Trends geguckt, die Videos sind meistens nicht schlecht,
die Videos sind meistens gut.
Videotrends ist halt eh eklig.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen, die Trends werden ja immer unprominenter platziert, weil ganz
im Ernst, ich wüsste gar nicht wo die Trends überhaupt sind.
Explore, Trending, was trendet denn hier?
Clash of Clans, so ein Schrott trendet, keckel alter.
Da ist nichts dabei, was ich gucken würde.
Helene Fischer, jawoll, endlich neue Helene Fischer Song.
Alter, ist ja noch schlimmer, dann habe ich meinen Key zum Entschlüsseln in der Cloud
liegen.
Das ist ja genau das, was ich haben will, ich möchte unbedingt das Passwort beziehungsweise
den Key zum Entschlüsseln meiner Daten in der Cloud speichern, ganz wichtig, kann mir
nichts besseres vorstellen.
Der View-Countrends gibt an, wie viele Gehirnzellen gestorben sind, ja aber nur bei einer Person.
Was schauen wir uns denn jetzt an, nee mein eigenes Video gucken wir uns nicht an, komm
wir gucken uns das an, ich bin mal gespannt was dabei rumkommt.
Wer ist aktuell die relevanteste Person auf YouTube, welche Themen werden am allermeisten
angeklickt?
Wer ist die relevanteste Person auf YouTube?
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt absolut nicht den leisesten, geplatzesten Schimmer, nicht den
kleinsten Hauch einer Ahnung, also früher hätte ich mal gesagt so was wie Pewdiepie,
aber das ist es ja garantiert nicht mehr, ganz am Anfang von YouTube war der größte
Abonnent, wie ist der Ray, nee irgendwas mit Johnson oder so, Ray Johnson, Ray Johnson,
William Johnson, Ray William Johnson, irgendwie so oder, Ray William Johnson, genau den gab's,
der war sau groß am Anfang, ich weiß gar nicht ob es den überhaupt noch gibt, gibt
es den überhaupt noch, ok, oh der macht jetzt nur noch Shorts oder was, alter, es geht ja
richtig ab, der hat mal jahrelang, jahrelang war der richtig, war der, war der, war der
richtig, der hat der Channel, WTF, mit Shorts hat er hier anscheinend sein neues Ding gefunden
man, krass, der Channel war mal voll im Arsch, krass, das hätte ich nicht gedacht das der
noch gibt, dick im Shorts Game, ja, Wahnsinn, und ansonsten jetzt hätte ich wirklich absolut
keine Ahnung wer die wichtigste Person auf YouTube oder die bekannteste oder so Person
auf YouTube ist, ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung, ich könnte das doch nicht mal für Deutschland
sagen, ich ist zum Beispiel Funk im Verhältnis zu klassischen Medienhäusern, eine Möglichkeit
wie man all das und noch viel mehr feststellen könnte wäre ein Jahr lang zu untersuchen,
was jeden Tag die angesagtesten Videos auf YouTube sind, auf gehts, das Ding ist nur
in den YouTube Trends sind immer 50 Videos gleichzeitig, das heißt wenn man, ja ok aber
man müsste sich das theoretisch wahrscheinlich auch angucken die Trends, sind die Trends
immer gleich oder sind die Trends schon personalisiert, also sprich müsste ich das immer mit einem
anonymen Tap aufmachen, das ein Jahr lang machen würde, wären das 18.250 Videos die
man untersuchen müsste, ja, um herauszufinden wer am meisten so getrendet ist und wer wäre
dumm genug sich das anzutun, ich auf jeden Fall nicht, ich hab dafür nämlich Praktikanten,
Kapitel 1 die Daten, wir, ich sag einfach mal wir, mein Team und ich, wir haben jeden
Abend zum gleichen Zeitpunkt in mühsamer Handarbeit ein Jahr lang eingetragen welche
YouTube Videos gerade in den YouTube Trends waren und jetzt denken vielleicht ein paar
von euch, hä, hätte man das nicht auch einfach mit einer Software automatisieren können,
ja, die Idee ist mir dann auch noch ein paar Monate gekommen, weil wir dann so ein paar
Lücken in den Daten hatten, weil die Praktikanten auch mal Urlaub wollten und dann hat Rezo
mir netterweise mit Nindo was gebaut, mit dem wir dann die Lücke in den Daten stopfen
konnten, größte Liebe deswegen an Rezo und an Nindo, Shoutout geht raus, falls ihr irgendwie
im Marketingbereich arbeitet und Nindo Pro noch nicht ausgecheckt habt, macht das allein
nur deswegen, weil Rezo hat dieses Video gerettet und dank fleißigen Praktikanten,
da hätte er sich mal zumindest die Haare blau färben können oder, Praktikantinnen und
dank Nindo haben wir also, die laut YouTube, rund 18.000 relevantesten Videos zwischen
dem 1. Februar 2021, mal ganz davon abgesehen, das könnte man ja sogar relativ easy ohne
irgendwelche Analyse-Tools machen, ich mein du weg hättest die, das könntest du wirklich
auf die absolut simpelste Art und Weise überhaupt machen, du wegettest dir einfach einmal abends
die Trend-Seite und web-scrapes dir dann irgendwas aus dem HTML raus, also das ist tatsächlich
sogar easy, da musst du weder YouTube-API noch sonstige Geschichten machen, also die
einfache Auswertung davon dürfte wahrscheinlich, und wenn YouTube sagt weget geht nicht, dann
nimmst du irgendeinen Chrome-Fangesteuert.
30. Januar 2022 auswerten können und falls ihr euch jetzt wieder fragt, hä, warum kommt
das Video dann im September, habt ihr schon mal versucht 18.000 die erfolgreichsten YouTube-Kanäle
laut den Trends, das erste was ich aus den Daten rauslesen konnte ist, du hast überhaupt
nicht jedes Video in den Trends geguckt, das stimmt überhaupt nicht, es gibt tatsächlich
nur ein paar hundert Kanäle, die es regelmäßiger in die Trends schaffen, für dieses Video
habe ich jetzt mal die Top 50 rausgesucht und tut mir jetzt am Anfang...
Gibt es eigentlich Herr Tutorial noch, aus irgendwelchen, weiß nicht, der war ja auch
angesagt 2010 rum, gibt es mal kurz, Herr Tutorial YouTube, tatsächlich den gibt's immer noch,
nur noch sehr unregelmäßig, hä? Ach sind sie jetzt alle aus Dubai wieder da, oder wie?
War das mit Steuern sparen in Dubai doch nicht so geil, bei den ganzen, das war ja mal eine
Zeit lang irgendwie der Trend, dass alle YouTuber nach Dubai gegangen sind.
Überlegt mal einmal kurz für euch, wen seht ihr auf Platz 1, was wäre so euer erster Instinkt
für den relevantesten, trendigsten YouTube-Kanal des letzten Jahres?
MrBeast, also nicht in Deutschland, international vielleicht, in Deutschland, Montana Black ist
jetzt auf YouTube nicht mehr so, das ist ja alles eher Twitch, ich hab keine Ahnung,
ich hab wirklich keinen Plan, wer da in Deutschland angesagt ist.
Marco, ich hab keine Ahnung, das war MrWissen2go, der war 33 Tage lang in den Trends im letzten
Jahr, LeroyWiltsWissen und StörrungF hatten jeweils einen Tag mehr, bei Filaude waren
es dann 35 und unter den trendigsten YouTube-Kanälen, da waren auch ein paar Unternehmen, wie das
Miniatur Wunderland.
Besonders spannend fand ich aber Marvin, der war auch 35 Tage in den Trends, natürlich
insbesondere wegen HydroHype aus dem letzten Jahr, der hatte in dem gesamten Zeitraum aber
nur 20 Videos hochgeladen und das liegt daran, dass nicht jedes Video immer 24 Stunden lang
trennt, manche trennten auch nur eine ganz kurze Zeit, manche aber eben auch für mehrere
Tage und von den 20 Videos, die Marvin im letzten Jahr hochgeladen hat, sind nur 5 nicht
in unseren Daten aufgetaucht, Marvin ist also wirklich einer der relevantesten YouTuber
des letzten Jahres gewesen, jedes Mal wenn er was hochgeladen hat, ist es quasi in den
Trends gelandet, es folgten dann Jinderuus, Couple on Tour, Shirin David, die auch nur
15 Videos hochgeladen hat und damit 36 Tage in den Trends war, Fresh Torge, Cold Mirror,
Vinny Piano, Cold Mirror gibt es auch noch, können wir jemanden, den ich schon mal gehört
habe, was von?
Vizcar Barca, den kenne ich auch noch aus Call of Duty Zeiten, wusste ich gar nicht,
dass der auch noch am Start ist, dann und das hätte ich nicht erwartet, die NFL und
dann MyLab, die nur 11 Videos hochgeladen hat in unserem Zeitraum und damit 37 Tage
in den Trends war und zwar jedes der 11 Videos war in den Trends und damit ist MyLab tatsächlich
der Kanal, der laut meinen Daten prozentual zum Upload-Pensum mit Abstand am meisten getrennt
ist, Julien Bellen hat das mit seinem Hauptkanal zwar auch geschafft, die haben drei Hauptvideos
hochgeladen und alle drei waren jeweils drei Tage in den Trends, aber basierend auf der
höheren Anzahl an Uploads könnte man sagen, dass MyLab die relevanteste YouTuberin im
letzten Jahr war, es gibt aber eben auch eine ganze Menge andere Kanäle, die weitaus mehr
Zeit in den Trends verbracht haben und um die geht es jetzt gleich und auch darum kommt
der Sponsor erstmal, ich wusste es, jetzt kommt erstmal der Sponsor, ich erkenne Überleitung
mittlerweile, wir suchen weiter nach dem relevantesten YouTube-Kanal Deutschlands laut den YouTube-Trends
und ich für immer noch, keiner von euch wird es erraten, aber nach MyLab kommt jetzt erstmal
der Sportstudio Fußball, Capital Bra, Varian, Joko und Klaas, Der Spiegel, Köln 5066, Alter,
ich gucke nichts davon, und dann ein Kanal von TheZone und da wird es richtig spannend,
denn eine Sache die ich festgestellt habe ist, nichts ist mehr in den deutschen Trends
als Fußballkanäle, ja das wundert mich in Deutschland jetzt wirklich nicht, TheZone
taucht nämlich noch vier weitere Male in den Top 50 auf mit fünf unterschiedlichen
Kanälen, insgesamt ist TheZone über all ihre Kanäle hinweg 425 mal in den Trends
gewesen, denn das Fußball in Deutschland in den Trends ist das wundert mich nicht, aber
das ist mehr als der DFB öffentlich-rechtliche Kanäle wie Sportstudio und Sportschau und
auch alle Sportkanäle von Sky zusammen, TheZone ist tatsächlich nach meiner Einschätzung
die relevanteste Medienmarke auf YouTube gewesen, wenn man die Trends als Grundlage
nimmt, die einzige Frage ist, kann Funk das toppen und es gibt natürlich noch einzelne
Kanäle die mehr in den Trends waren, in den Top 50 folgen noch Clash of Clans, Bullion
Jam, Maxi-Fi, internationale Kanäle sind auch dabei, Dude Perf, Maxi-Fi nicht der mit
dem mit dem ähm mit diesem Dinosaurier Schlafanzug, Broadstars, MrBeast, Survival Magic, ja gut
MrBeast das wundert mich nicht, Team Harrison, das Musiklabel Life is PainTV, Trimax, der
deutsche Kanal von kurz gesagt und Sam, ja okay das, das ist tatsächlich eines der
wenigen Channels die hier drin sind, die ich ab und zu mal gucke, und jetzt sind wir schon
bei, ich kenne die meisten da, chat wie gehts euch, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich kenne
90% der Channels nicht, in den Top 10 und eine Sache möchte ich da dazu sagen, von
den Top 10 gehören nur 5 Plätze klassischen YouTube-Creatern, allerdings gehört uns der
Top Platz, davor kommen aber noch Laser Luca, Julia Beautix, BibisBeautyPalace und Fritz
Meineke, der hat im letzten Jahr Seven VersusWald rausgebracht, das war das Format des Jahres
und das sieht man hier und das sieht man auch in den Trends, wenn man alle Reacts und Videos
die rund um Seven VersusWald entstanden sind mitzählt, dann waren tatsächlich 92 Tage
Seven VersusWald Inhalte in den Trends und jetzt bleiben natürlich nur noch die Top
2 Plätze und ich muss sagen, beide haben mich mega überrascht, 123 Tage lang in den Trends,
mehr als jeden dritten Tag, war Berlin Tag und Nacht, Berlin Tag und Nacht, dieser Schrott
Alter, ist so viel in den Trends, dass als wir auswerten wollten, welche Themen und Wortkombinationen
in Videotiteln am meisten trenden, Berlin Tag und Tag und Nacht mehr vorgekommen sind
in der Analyse, als ich habe, mehr als FIFA 22, nur Official Video Produced by Music Video
und Champions League kommen noch mehr vor und wenn man sich drei Wortkombinationen anguckt
sind es Official Music Video, Berlin Tag und Nacht, Seven VersusWald, Clash of Clans ist
auch so hoch, das ist Wild und UEFA Champions League, aber wer war denn jetzt der YouTube
Kanal, der am meisten in den Trends war? Es ist JP Performance, hättet ihr das gedacht?
JP Performance ist der YouTube Kanal über alle Kanäle hinweg, wenigstens kenne ich
den ersten Platz, in den Trends war 128 Tage lang und ehrlich gesagt, ich kann es mir nicht
erklären, Fritz Meinicke, Marvin, Mylab, Fußball, aber Autos, die hätte ich irgendwie kommen
sehen, aber JP Performance doppelt so oft wie der nächste klassische YouTuber unter ihm und
um unter den top 100 trendigsten Kanälen zu sein, muss man im Jahr nur 20 Tage in den Trends gewesen
sein, JP Performance war 108 Tage lang mehr in den Trends, die haben doch in seiner Firma
irgendeinen Trick rausgefunden, wie man die Trends manipuliert, also ich kann es mir nicht
erklären, ich habe den Trick nicht, aber eine Sache, die ich festgestellt habe, ist Kanäle mit
weniger Uploads trenden mehr, Marvin, Julien Bam, Mylab oder auch mein Kanal, ich war neun Tage in
den Trends mit sechs von meinen acht Uploads, die ich im letzten Jahr hatte, abonniert meinen Kanal,
ich spiele noch nicht so viel, wie kommt man eigentlich in die Trends? Möglichst viele Views in einem Tag oder
oder muss das irgendeinen YouTube-Typ-Hand rauspicken oder? Ich lade nur acht mal hoch,
das Abo lohnt sich. Kapitel 3, wie schneidet Funk ab? Wie oft warst du in den Trends? Wahrscheinlich nullmal?
Natürlich hat mich ein anderer YouTuber zu diesem Experiment inspiriert, Coffee Break, der hat vor dreieinhalb
Jahren schon mal eine ähnliche Trends-Analyse in den USA gemacht, bei ihm ging es viel darum,
wie viel Trends wird in den USA von Late-Night-Shows und amerikanischen Fernsehsendern beherrscht,
für Deutschland fand ich deswegen eine spannende Frage, wie trendy ist Funk eigentlich? In den
Top 50-Kanälen haben wir ja schon acht Projekte von Funk gesehen und insgesamt laut meinen Daten
war Funk letztes Jahr 548 mal in den Trends, also mehr, weitaus mehr als The Zone noch, allerdings
natürlich auch mit mehr einzelnen Kanälen, das hier, das sind die 35 Funk-Projekte, die ich in den
Trends finden konnte. Funk ist auf jeden Fall die mit Abstand größte einzelne Quelle für extra
für YouTube produzierten Content, der dann in den Trends landet, aber über alle Videos hinweg wollte
ich mir auch noch mal die Verteilung angucken, klassische YouTube-Kanäle haben rund 45% aller
Trends ausgemacht, Werbung von Unternehmen waren so bei 3%, Filme und Spieltrailer bei 4%, Musik bei
14% und Produktionen von größeren Medienhäusern bei 25%, zwischenzeitlich waren auch noch 7%
Shorts, die waren zeitweise in den Trends, jetzt haben die ihre eigenen Trends, das waren dann
meistens virale Hits von random Leuten, sehr spannend fand ich aber auch noch, dass Gronkh und Unge die
größten Kanäle nach Abos waren, die verhältnismäßig am wenigsten in den Trends waren für ihre Abos.
Gronkh war ein einziges Mal in den Trends. Ja gut, das kann ich insofern nachvollziehen, Let's Plays
ist jetzt ja was, da sticht jetzt kein einziges, also kein einzelnes Video in der Form raus,
dass das dann übelst abgeht. Unge spielt nur 9 Tage, genauso viel wie ich, das hat aber glaube
ich einen Grund, die 9 mal dir in den Trends waren, das waren alles Videos, die alle super wichtig
waren aus seinem Leben. Unge taucht aber der Rest ist irgendwelches Reaction Zeug tatsächlich mit seinen
Reacts ganz oft in den Gaming Trends auf. Das sind separate Trends aus irgendeinem Grund und die haben
wir nicht extra ausgewertet und wahrscheinlich war da noch eine Menge los, da waren wahrscheinlich
auch Leute wie Knossi oder Montana Black und deswegen sind die hier nicht, obwohl die eigentlich
ziemlich relevant sind. Falls ihr sonst noch Fragen oder auch Ideen habt, was wir noch mit den Daten
machen können, wenn ihr Fragen habt, hey ist dieser YouTuber in den Trends gewesen und wie oft?
Ich muss sagen, wie gesagt 90 Prozent der Kanäle haben überhaupt nichts gesagt, aber ich ignoriere
zum größten Teil eh. Also YouTube Deutschland ignoriere ich zum allergrößten Teil und auch
Mainstream YouTube international geht mir sonst wo vorbei. Weniger Pfeif hat, viel viel weniger
Pfeif hat. Wenn David Kriesel das ausgewertet hätte, der hätte dir gesagt, welche YouTuber
mit welchem YouTuber fremd gehen aktuell anhand der Video Uploadzeiten und Daten. Kann ich mich
trauen das anzuklicken? Der langsame Tod der Trends. Ich werde gleich gucken. Moment, das ist falsch,
das hier ist ja gar nicht mein. Das ist ja, ich habe zu viele Tabs Leute. Ich wette. Zu viele Tabs,
blicke ich dann mal durch. Don't commit secrets, das ist korrekt. Leute, es ist letzte Woche wieder
was passiert, das habe ich nicht für möglich gehalten. Ich habe es auch, ich habe es ja schon
auf Twitter gepostet. Nein, nicht mal neuer Kubernetes Cluster. Das da. Warum fragen mich Leute,
die Senior Admin sind, wo ihr SSH-Verzeichnis ist? Da frage ich mich immer, wann wirst du zum Senior
Admin bei uns? Musst du einfach nur lang genug dabei sein? Keine Ahnung. Okay, zu seiner Ehrenrettung
muss man sagen, es ist Windows. Aber es geht nicht darum, wo es unter Windows liegt, sondern wo es
in WSL liegt. Und ganz im Ernst, einem Senior Admin traue ich das durchaus zu, das auch in WSL zu
finden. Und selbst, wer das nicht findet, einfach mal in Google einzugeben SSH Directory Linux. Und
dann findet das auch. Es ist ja nicht, als wäre das super geil versteckt gewesen. Also,
ich verstehe es teilweise nicht. Alter, die Leute bei uns, die haben teilweise richtige Profis am
Werk. Ich frage mich dann immer, wenn du mit sowas Senior Admin werden kannst, was kommt denn als
Ding? Bin ich dann Uroper Admin oder wie? Ist aber nicht nur bei euch so. Ja, ich weiß. Es ist
normal, dass 90% der Leute keine Ahnung haben von ihrem Job. Der Kerl war noch älter als ich.
Wahnsinn. Also Sachen, die hält man nicht für möglich. 8 free Websites,
you probably then, das haben wir schon geguckt. Stadia. Alles rund um Cloud Gaming. Auch dieser
Channel hat, glaube ich, gerade Probleme. Das können wir uns sonst noch angucken hier.
Why most Google Employees quit after 1.1 years? Und das ist ein Wort, das macht mir immer was,
das macht mir immer zu schaffen. Ich kann mir nicht merken, ob es Average heißt. Wahrscheinlich
ist es sogar, je nachdem, wen du fragst. Es ist so wie Garage. Manche sagen Garage, manche
sagen Garage und wir. Aber das Schlimmste ist immer noch, was Englisch angeht, dass die ihr
W W aussprechen. Das werde ich nie lernen. Ich musste letzte Woche übrigens mit einem
rein englischsprachigen Telekom Techniker wieder Server fixen bei uns. Das ist immer lustig,
weil das ist kein Native Speaker und ich bin auch kein Native Speaker, aber irgendwie funktioniert
es trotzdem. Was ich noch nicht probiert habe, paar Twitch Emails einzubauen, zu checken, ob
er sich da auskennt. Also von seinem Namen her würde ich sagen, er kommt aus Tschechien
oder so. Und bei mir hörst du halt ganz klar, dass ich German bin. Da sind sie nicht die
einzigen. Why most Google Employees quit after one? Lass mich raten. Ich predikte mal, warum
die meisten Google Mitarbeiter nach einem Jahr aufhören. Oder nach etwas über einem
Jahr. Wahrscheinlich gibt es nach einem Jahr einen Bonus und den wollen noch alle irgendwie
mitnehmen. Ich gehe davon aus, dass es einfach deutlich stressiger ist, als man sich das
Ganze vorgestellt hat. Und dass dieses Ganze, wir haben uns so lieb und spielen den ganzen
Tag Konsole im Büro und chillen auf der Terrasse, nicht der Realität entspricht und in Wirklichkeit
kaum einer diese Dinger wirklich verwendet, weil sie dann quasi schäpp angeguckt werden,
wenn sie es verwenden. Das ist ein bisschen so zu einer Sache, die ich selbst erlebt habe.
Dort wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe und wo ich danach beim Internet oder beim Provider
gearbeitet habe, die hatten auch eine Bar oben im Dachgeschoss, die hatten so die typischen
Tischkicker-Geschichten, irgendeinen Entspannungsraum und wisst ihr wie oft das Zeug verwendet wurde?
Nahezu nie. Warum wurde das nicht verwendet? Naja, weil dich alle Schäpp angeguckt haben,
wie du gehst in den Entspannungsraum, anstatt weiter zu arbeiten. Und wir können es in Bewerbungszeug
gut verkaufen, dass es sowas gibt. Die hatten aber auch andere komische Sachen, also ich
bin froh, dass ich da weg bin. Die hatten auch andere Sachen, die hatten sowas wie Freitag
abends, wurde dann immer noch was getrunken oben zusammen und ihr wisst, wie viel bock
ich auf irgendwelche sozialen Events mit random Leuten habe. Und ich war ja selten da, glücklicherweise,
dass ich da hin. Aber du wurdest da auch Schäpp angeguckt, wenn du gesagt hast, ich gehe
jetzt einfach heim. So nach dem Motto, ja wie du willst 19 Uhr nicht noch mit deinen Kollegen
am Freitag was trinken. Ich habe gesagt, nee und 19 Uhr schon mal gar nicht, 16 Uhr wenn
es hochkommt. Also ganz im Ernst, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es in Google ähnlich ist
plus noch schlimmer. So gucken wir uns das mal an. Der hat aber sein Bass ganz schön
hochgedreht.
Wie gesagt, unterm Strich, unterm Strich, ich gehe davon aus, es ist einfach
zu stressig. Was die Burnout, wenn man so will. Ist das Essmongold gewesen gerade?
Was zum? Nee, nee, aber es sah gerade aus dem Augenwinkel echt so aus.
Die Musik wieder. Ja, okay, wir haben jetzt genug aufregende Musik gehabt. Ja, auf erzähl.
And check that out!
Das ist das, was Ken Walks, ein externe Mitarbeiter, in einem kontroversierten TikTok gesagt hat, das dieses Jahr viral ging.
Die jungen Mitarbeiter, die sich auf die Firma befinden, erlauben, dass sie eine tolle Arbeitslife-Balanz haben,
leiden leckeres Essen und spielen Ping-Pong mit Kollegen.
Ja, okay, jetzt mal ernsthaft. Also wer das wirklich glaubt, dem ist, okay, da sind meistens Leute, die kommen direkt von der Uni, die hatten wahrscheinlich noch keinen Kontakt mit der Realität. Also wir haben uns doch schon total oft hier im Stream Videos angeguckt, diese Videos.
One day in the life of bla bla bla, ja, at Uber, at Google, at sonst was. Und man kann doch sofort erkennen, was realistisch ist und was nicht ist. Diese Videos, die am Anfang sich erstmal einen Smoothie machen, dann erstmal irgendwie auf der Terrasse rumchillen, dann erstmal eine Runde Ping-Pong spielen, zwischendurch mal eine halbe Stunde programmieren oder so, da ist uns doch allen klar und bewusst, das ist alles fake.
Aber gut, wenn man das natürlich glaubt und mit der Erwartung hingeht, dann ist ja, dann ist die Enttäuschung natürlich vorprogrammiert. Was hat der da für ein Stuhl?
Das ist eigentlich richtig clever von Google. Moment, wann gibt's die? Wann gibt's die Dinger?
Ja gut, guck mal, du kriegst das 18 Uhr, 18.30 kriegst du, freedom times, ja, es ist 18 Uhr und 18.30. 18.30 bin ich seit ungefähr zweieinhalb Stunden schon daheim. 18.30, das heißt im Endeffekt, du bist bis vorneweg 19 Uhr beschäftigt.
19 Uhr auf der Arbeit, bis 19 Uhr und danach machen die wahrscheinlich noch irgendwelche komischen anderen Entertainment-Dinger oder so und die meisten Leute schlafen dann wahrscheinlich auch im Büro, weil warum sollte ich jetzt noch heimfahren?
Das heißt, die fahren da morgens mit hin und abends mit heim und dann kommt noch mal eine Stunde, zwei Stunden drauf.
Wahrscheinlich ist es dann sogar so, ey, das ist doppelt gut für Google, gell, die Leute können dann quasi diese sinnlost-Tasks wie E-Mails lesen oder auf irgendwelche komischen Dinge antworten und so, das können die im Bus machen und dann haben die auf der Arbeit wirklich Zeit, 10 Stunden Five-Hat-Kram durchzuarbeiten.
Kein Wunder, das hältst du ja nicht aus. Du hältst ja nicht aus, 10 Stunden am Tag hirnanstrengende Arbeit zu machen. Kein Wunder, dass du das nicht länger als ein Jahr aushältst.
Was?
Ja, genau. Die Musik im Hintergrund. Ich nicht. Nein, nein.
Leute, was habe ich denn von einem Abendessen auf der Arbeit, wenn ich da für zweieinhalb Stunden länger da bleiben muss und ansonsten außer der Arbeit kein anderes Leben mehr habe?
Also ist das ein kostenloses Abendessen wirklich das, was das aufwiegt?
Die Abendessen musst du wahrscheinlich nicht bezahlen.
Stress, ja. Alter, die Musik, man, ist ja gut. Alter, reg dich ab.
Wie soll man eigentlich arbeiten in so einem Environment?
Guckt euch das mal an, wie soll man da arbeiten? Wie soll er bitte schön arbeiten? Was geht da im Hintergrund bei dem Abendessen?
Ich meine, okay, das ist jetzt ja nicht Google und das ist von irgendeinem anderen Video, aber was ist das?
Ja, das glaube ich denen sofort. Leute, und wisst ihr was? Ich sage euch mal was hier.
53% sagen, ja, unser Job ist extrem stressvoll und davon, also nicht von diesen 53%, obendrauf kommen nochmal 40%, die sich selbst nicht eingestehen wollen oder nicht zugeben wollen.
Das sind viel mehr. Das sind die 53%, die es schon realisiert haben. Die anderen 40% haben es wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht eingesehen oder wollen sich nicht eingestehen.
Unlimited Vacation ist auch so ein Ding. Wer traut sich bitteschön, Unlimited Vacation zu nehmen, also irgendwie 8 Wochen im Jahr oder so, wenn du dann immer noch treibangeguckt wirst, dieses Unlimited, da gibt es doch sogar, da gab es von nicht allzu langer Zeit eine Untersuchung zu.
Das Unlimited Vacation in der Regel dazu führt, dass die Leute weniger Urlaub nehmen als sonst. Also wenn einer 20, keine Ahnung, einer hat 25 Tage Urlaub, dann nimmt er das und wenn du Unlimited hast, dann führt es eher dazu, dass die Leute weniger nehmen.
Ja, ist so, die nehmen sich weniger Urlaub.
Ja, okay, hey, so einen Ruheraum haben wir jetzt bei der Arbeit, wo ich bin, plus dort, wo ich vorher beim Provider gearbeitet habe auch und diesen Ruheraum nimmt niemand in Anspruch.
Stimmt.
Das wird früher oder später auch so passieren.
Werder wirst du Chef angeguckt.
Ist das jetzt Werbung? Ist das jetzt einfach übergegangen in Werbung oder?
Das ist jetzt einfach Werbung.
Ich frage mich ganz ehrlich, wie gut klappt die Zusammenarbeit eigentlich in so einem Fall?
Also wenn jeder quasi sich als Konkurrent zu jedem fühlt und jeder der Meinung ist, er muss permanent den anderen irgendwie übertreffen und ausstechen, arbeitet man dann überhaupt sinnvoll zusammen?
Geht das überhaupt? Oder fuckt man sich die ganze Zeit ab? Das würde tatsächlich manche Produkte von Google erklären. Ja, das sind dann quasi so halbe One-Man-Shows mit Leuten, die versuchen, sich immer gegenseitig zu übertreffen mit anderen Dingern.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Team vs. Team ist. Wahrscheinlich ist es nicht mal Team vs. Team. Wahrscheinlich ist es jeder gegen jeden.
Also ja, hier Chet, ich glaube, ihr habt Recht. Ich glaube, ihr habt Recht, ja. Aber man sollte sich doch mal, also guck mal, ich glaube tatsächlich, dass es so ist.
Wahrscheinlich hast du dann auch Psychologen und alles. Aber muss ich mal überlegen.
Erst schafft man die Voraussetzungen dafür, dass die Leute sich quasi gegenseitig so krassen Konkurrenz haben, dass die Leute sich quasi permanent untereinander irgendwie selbst Konkurrenz machen und dann versuchst du obendrauf, irgendwelche Gespräche zu führen, dass das nicht so oft passiert.
Vielleicht sollte man eigentlich das eigentliche Problem mal beheben, anstatt sich dann irgendwelche Psychologen draufzuschmeißen.
Also, wir sehen.
Was, was, was stand da? Sekunde, meine Eier.
Ja, das ist ja leider bei vielen großen Dingern so.
Nein, nicht Brick.
Aber zu Facebook würde ich auch nicht gehen.
Da ist was dran.
Habe ich noch nie was von gehört.
Die meisten Startups, das wird ja auch nichts.
Nee, was von gehört, genau.
Das, das, das ist tatsächlich, kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es für viele auch ein Grund ist, dass sie, dass sie zu Google gehen, weil sie sich denken, selbst wenn ich bei Google nach einer Weile aufhör, macht sich einfach gut im Lebenslauf.
Und das macht es mit Sicherheit.
Ja, bei manchen Google Produkten, finde ich, merkt man das schon.
Wahrscheinlich, das werden sich garantiert viele denken, so nach dem Motto Alter, dann haue ich halt ab, dann habe ich es bei mir im Lebenslauf stehen und gut ist.
Ganz ehrlich, das wäre nichts für mich, da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Erstens würden die mich niemals nehmen.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal zu einem Interview eingeladen werden, aber selbst wenn, ich würde es auch nicht machen wollen.
Da hätte ich wirklich keinen Bock drauf.
Ich meine, mir ist es ja jetzt schon dort, wo ich bin und das ist ja wahrscheinlich im Vergleich zu Google da wirklich Kindergarten.
Teilweise zu stressig oder zu nervig, also insofern, ne, da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Ich muss mich hier um Stream und YouTube und sonst was kümmern können.
Geld sorgen habe ich auch keine, deswegen ist es bei mir auch nicht so, dass ich sagen müsste, Alter, ich hänge so an meinem Job oder ich hänge so an dieser einen Sache
oder ich muss mich da jetzt besonders anstrengen, dass es irgendwie super gut aussieht.
Ich mache das bevorzugt, worauf ich Bock habe und das ziemlich gut.
Ich bin nämlich selten zufrieden mit irgendwelchen Sachen, also das muss man sagen.
Ich glaube, das merkt man manchmal auch bei irgendwelchen Bastel-Streams.
Ich habe da ganz spezielle Vorstellungen, wie was aussehen muss und so diese 0815 Lösungen, die es oftmals gibt, die gefallen mir nicht und die reichen mir nicht.
Und ich bastel teilweise 30 Stunden an irgendwas rum, nur um eine Sache zu verbessern, wo andere sagen würden dazu, ey, das ist doch Kleinkram.
Also dann drücke ich halt zweimal anstatt einmal, wie ein Juckts, ja, aber das geht nicht so ab, dass ich zweimal drücken muss,
dass ich lieber, und 30 Stunden reicht ja nicht, dass ich lieber zwei Monate dran bastel, dass ich noch einmal drücken muss anstatt zweimal.
Ja, und so mache ich das auf der Arbeit auch. Also ich mache vieles halt super, wie soll ich sagen, so ausführlich und korrekt.
Was ist korrekt? Nach meiner Art und Weise korrekt, was jetzt nicht zwangsläufig heißt, dass das jeder so sehen müsste.
Die Prozess optimiert ist das bei mir eher nicht. Prozess optimiert wird ja heißen, ich mache das nach irgendwelchen Abläufen, die sich andere Leute ausgedacht haben.
Ja, Perfektionismus trifft es besser, wobei es meine Ansicht von Perfektion ist und die werden wahrscheinlich viele andere nicht teilen.
Ja, es gibt ein ganz, ein blödes Beispiel, ein blödes Beispiel, wo ich viel Energie reinstecke, was eigentlich keinen Sinn, keinen Sinn gibt.
Aber, also fällt mir zu ein, weil ich das letztens hatte. Letztendlich macht es keinen Sinn, aber ich bin der Meinung, dass wenn du Skript oder Kommando Zeilen Tools hast,
und die ein bisschen ausführlich sind, die sollten ein Minus Minus Version unterstützen und es sollte ein Minus Minus Version sein.
Es sollte nicht minus V sein, es sollte nicht Minus Version sein, nein, ich bin der Meinung, es sollte Minus Minus Version sein.
Und ich bin da letztens bei einem von uns so auf den Sack gegangen, dass das gefälligst Minus Minus Version sein muss.
Das hat tatsächlich eingebaut, dass es Minus Minus Version als Parameter gibt.
Nee, Minus V geht nicht. Siehste, das ist auch so was. Minus V geht nicht, Minus V ist Verbose in vielen Fällen.
Ich will Minus Minus Version haben. Aber Minus V und Minus Minus Version ist auch okay, wenn es nicht Minus Minus Verbose noch gibt.
Weil dann sollte es Minus V, Minus Minus, V sollte Minus Minus Verbose sein.
Nee, das ist das Springtisch, das ist kein Problem. Kann es doch beides geben.
Egal, das sind so Dinger. Und ich habe letztens beispielsweise auch was fertig gebastelt, da ging es darum,
dass wir von zwei Datenbanken in eine dritte Datenbank was importieren.
So und die dritte Datenbank hatte ein Webinterface, wo man dann gescheit filtern kann und sowas.
Und ich habe den Import gebaut, das ist im Prinzip relativ easy gewesen.
Beide anderen, Datenbank ist falsches Wort, zwei andere Web-Services.
Du kannst über zwei APs konntest du abfragen. Daten aus dem eins ist in der E. Alter, PowerShell Style.
Piss dich, Aldo.
Geh fort. PowerShell E. Das ist ja ganz abwartig.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Also, du musstest einfach nur an zwei APs dran gehen und das dann über die AP in die dritte Schnittstelle pumpen.
Es war im Prinzip easy. Ich war fertig, es hat alles funktioniert, aber was habe ich gemacht?
Ich habe den restlichen Tag tatsächlich ordentliche CLI-Bedienung eingebaut in das Tool.
Aktuell, also das erste, was ich zusammen gewurschtet habe, war im Prinzip ein Programm, das hast du gestartet
und das ging hardcoded zu diesen zwei Services, hat die Sachen gepullt und in den dritten gepusht.
Und was habe ich mir gedacht danach? Okay, jetzt ist das fertig, jetzt funktioniert das.
Und jetzt bauen wir noch ein, minus minus Help, minus minus Version.
Dann bauen wir noch Parameter ein, minus minus Source, minus minus Destination.
Dann habe ich am Ende irgendwie noch mal vier Stunden dran rumgebastelt, dass das Ding ordentliche Command- und Zeilenbedienung hatte.
Und ordentliche Ausgabe und wir haben sogar mittlerweile, stellt euch mal vor, du musst am Anfang deinen Account und Passwort eingeben,
dass du dich bei diesem einen Webservice einloggen kannst.
Und mittlerweile ist sogar die Passwort-Eingabe farbig.
Command- und Zeilenbedienung halt. Das fragt sich hier Passwort für Service XY oder Credentials für Passwort XY eingeben
und sogar wenn du das Passwort eingibst, ist es ausgesternet in der Konsole.
Und das OS unabhängig, also nicht einfach Readline hier unter Linux oder so, in der Shell auf einem Betriebssystem unabhängig.
Gut, natürlich habe ich auch fertige Libraries dafür verwendet.
Also wer.NET verwendet, dem kann ich immer nur empfehlen, das hier zu verwenden für
Command- und Zeilen-Krempel und Command- und Zeilen-Formatierung, POG-Library, ja.
Sowas, also da habe ich halt, ja, manch einer will sagen, Max, warum machst du 4 Stunden an dem Toolraum, was eigentlich noch funktioniert?
Aber, tja, ich bin halt der Meinung, ich bin, das weiß ich, das widerstrebt mir dann, das so halb fertig da rumhängen zu lassen.
Und das muss dann auch Minus Minus Version haben und Minus Minus Help und Minus H und Minus Minus Source und Minus Minus Destination und Minus Minus User
und ordentliche Hilfetext und ordentliche Input-Validierung und, tja.
Wechselst du wegen Manif- oder können wir auch ein Video zugucken jetzt? Ich habe doch irgendwo hier was offen.
Ja, das können wir uns gleich angucken. Ja.
So sieht es bei mir. Übrigens, falls irgendjemand meinen Home Assistant Addon verwendet für seinen Fiat.
Guckt mal Leute, ich habe es weiterentwickelt. Man kann jetzt sogar sein Auto fernsteuern. Man kann jetzt sogar an sein Auto Befehle schicken, nämlich
GPS Location updaten, Batteriestatus updaten, man kann die Lichter blinken lassen, man kann das Laden starten, man kann den Kofferraum öffnen oder man kann die Klimaanlage einschalten.
Remote mit der Integration hier.
Ach ja, übrigens, wisst ihr was bei Fiat äußerst pepega ist, was sehr, sehr merkwürdig ist bei Fiat? Man kann das Preconditioning vom Auto, also quasi die Temperatur, die man eingestellt hat, kann man einschalten, aber man kann es offiziell nicht wieder ausschalten.
Also sprich, wer die offizielle Fiat App verwendet, der kann nur sagen, bitte Auto jetzt heizen und die Heizung danach nicht wieder ausschalten, außer er setzt sich ins Auto und drückt aus.
Und ich hab was gefunden, ich hab nen Befehl gefunden, ehrlich gesagt, im dekompilierten Android App Source, das wollte ich hier aber nicht on stream machen, ich hab nen Befehl gefunden, um das angeblich wieder auszuschalten, aber ich weiß halt nicht, was es macht.
Deswegen hab ich das rausgelassen, deswegen musste ich erstmal ne Option setzen, wenn man das verwenden will.
Wie ist das gesichert, sollte nicht von jedem einsehbar sein, wenn du das Addon installierst, musst du dein Passwort und dein Account für die Fiat Webseite eingeben.
Das geht über den Online Service.
Und deinen PIN musst du eingeben.
Leute, ich hab nen Problem, ich muss mal aufs Klo.
Pepo Pupu.
Sekunde Leute.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
AFK Klo.
2-3 Minuten.